I'm Cara Santa Maria for Wired and I'm
here with slash to talk about nothing
left to fear a new film that he scored
so what was it like writing the whole
soundtrack to a film it brings out a
completely different musician in me when
I do it it's like for some reason
looking at a picture looking at a
storyboard reading a script or looking
at the the movement on the screen
inspires me to do something that I
cannot do when I'm just writing a song
to make it a regular Rock just looking
for a town called stall you wouldn't be
the new pattern would you actually yes
how'd you do that
Patrick Kingman asked me to keep an eye
out for you and so it's pretty
fascinating even to myself what comes up
you know and so this isn't the first
movie that I've scored I did another
movie a couple years ago called this is
not a movie which was like this really
low-budget movie with Peter Coyote in it
and it was really great because that was
my first full-length squirrel
so what about this film particularly
like what's what's the vibe of it and
how are you inspired to write it
I see the vibe it's a it's a very somber
very haunting and dark movie but half
the movie is very light and summery and
then it it's it's an interesting sort of
slow burn to where it gets really sort
of scary and all that but the movie in
short is based in this town called stall
Kansas which is a real place and it's
got this sort of Mythology to it that is
one of the seven gateways to hell
this place nice people
that's a heavy thing to write - yeah
well and so you know I started before I
think before anything was really shot I
started writing songs for it and
actually the the main song for the for
the film that I did with Myles Kennedy
was one of those tunes that before I had
even seen anything but I knew the story
but you just start to work in that frame
of mind of thinking of the characters
the vibe that it makes you feel yeah and
I'm really excited to see the film to
see the score it sounds awesome and
thank you so much for talking to me oh
it's great talking here we have to talk
dinosaurs